dans l'arctique le réchauffement
climatique est plus prononcée
qu'ailleurs sur la planète pour
documenter ce phénomène une expédition
scientifique
s'ils décident dérivés avec la banquise
pendant tout l'hiver dernier 2019
le brise-glace power stone quitte son
port d'attache en allemagne charge et
matériels et de scientifiques
il entreprend un voyage donnant sur plus
de dix mille kilomètres
sa destination le pôle nord pour ces
anglais c'est tout l'hiver
[Musique]
dix ans il a fallu pour planifier
l'expédition et la finance est
l'équivalent de 220 millions de dollars
canadiens l'institut de recherche
allemand alfred waggner pilote le projet
le but de l'expédition mosaïque est à la
fois simple et complexe s'accrocher en
un immense fragments banquise se laisser
dériver avec lui dans le courant
transpolaires en frôlant aux normes
le professeur markus rex et le chef de
l'expédition en arctique le
réchauffement est au moins deux fois
plus rapide qu'ailleurs encore plus en
hiver et c'est là où les modèles
climatiques représentent le plus grand
degré d'incertitude l'incertitude vient
en partie du manque de données sur
l'interaction complexe entre l'eau la
glace et l'air au pôle nord en hiver le
but de l'expédition mauzé c'est d'en
récolter tous les jours et le
déploiement est très ambitieux on parle
d'installer sur un immense morceau de
banquise en dérive
un véritable village scientifique une
station pour des submersibles des puits
d'échantillonnage d'où les instruments
pour caractériser la glace et la neige
une station météo pour mesurer la
température les précipitations les gaz
et les aérosols des appareils pour
suivre des mouvements et la déformation
de la glace
en plus des mesures prises du haut des
airs
mais une fois arrivés dans l'arctique
surprise la glace est plus mince que
prévu on met des jours a trouvé un
morceau de banquise assez grand et
robuste pour s'y accrocher
une vingtaine d'étudiants sélectionnés à
travers le monde participe au
déploiement des instruments à partir
d'un deuxième brise glace qui sera
l'hôte temporairement le québécois alex
mabro vite fait partie du groupe
il étudie la télédétection dans les
milieux terrestres article c'est sa
première expérience sur une banquise
elle doit avec la première fois j'étais
dans l'église las une certaine
organisation de l'eau où je me trouvais
moi j'étais éloigner la stylisation que
je l'étais le cas ce moment là sur
quelque chose sous lequel il devait y
avoir 3 4 km2 d'océan glacé
mais le temps presse les nuits polaires
approche
le site est vaste le déploiement doit se
faire par beau temps et grand froid
dès les premières semaines de collecte
l'équipe constate à quel point la glace
émouvante
tout bouge autour de la glace a été un
défi pour les instruments se déplaçait
et il fallait rebâtir nos sites
les morceaux de banquise se séparer
s'entrechoquent sous leurs yeux
malgré tous les travaux avancent chaque
jour permet de décrire en détail la
composition de la neige et de la glace
de la faune marine et des échanges
thermiques entre l'océan et l'atmosphère
au milieu de ces artistes réchauffement
sentir sur les côtes également don du
côté canadien
il est vert social à une fonte accélérée
de la glace par exemple sur l'écho mais
cette nouvelle eau douce le voit se
déverser dans l'océan arctique qui va
affecter les cours en ces années qui se
trouve désormais tout le travail se fait
dans l'obscurité totale de la nuit
polaire
en permanence on scrute l'horizon pour
détecter la présence d'ours polaires
certains sont venus flair et des
équipements
[Musique]
cinq mois après son départ le navire a
parcouru plus de 4000 kilomètres et a
commencé sa lente dérive vers le pôle
nord
en parallèle on doit assurer le relais
des équipes de recherche d'abord à la mi
décembre puis plus tard à la fin février
un brise-glace russe va mettre un mois
pour se rendre au pôle ashton les
suissesses juli h mal est d'abord fait
pour se rendre à pau les acheter on peut
parler d'une petite expédition en soi
mais c'était difficile parce que on a dû
voyager jusqu'au point mort pressé et en
hiver c'est s'était jamais fait deux
semaines après leur arrivée début mars
la clarté du jour revient sur l'arctique
[Musique]
dulière chemari ses collègues hamas des
données sur les aérosols ces mini
particules qui contribue à former des
nuages
elle veut entre autres quantifier leur
présence en hiver au dessus de l'océan
il distinguer ceux d'origine naturelle
dessus issu de la pollution
atmosphérique l'atmosphère lactique en
hiver ont fait est très pollué on peut
s'imaginer qu'il y a l'air froid qui est
comme une cloche de fromages sur la
petite donc tous les émissions dans ce
club c'est accumulent dans l'atmosphère
de là
dans ses dérives le pachtoune parcours
plus de 2000 kilomètres en zigzag
il passe à 156 km du pôle nord puis
lakovic 19 bouscule les plans
le brise-glace doit temporairement
quitté sa banquise pour un aller-retour
à svalbard en norvège pour récupérer les
scientifiques qui ne peuvent le
rejoindre
[Musique]
un mois plus tard à la mi juin
le power stone retrouve son morceau de
banquise à la dérive les mesures
reprennent du haut des airs
on poursuit les relevés de l'épaisseur
de glace avec cette espèce de torpilles
la glace fond maintenant impudeur en
juillet le navire quête la banquise qui
se disloque complètement
le pôle austin va remettre le cap sur le
pôle nord durant tout l'été avant de
rentrer en allemagne à la mi octobre
après un voyage depuis deux noms
[Musique]
il revient chargé de données inédites
une mine d'or pour les générations
futures de chercheurs comme alex pour
moi qui d'élus anciens j'ai
définitivement quelque chose à travers
lequel je vais passer une partie ma
carrière nation des a travaillé sur
donné là à tenter d exploiter du milieu
des décennies durant lesquelles on
risque d'assister à la dérive du climat
arctique et d'une autre
[Musique]